we ask our Medical Aid team and medical
contributors Dr Nicole Sapphire and Dr
Mark Siegel in studio with us good to
see you both
all right Dr Nicole
top of everything that we have already
seen and witnessed and heard
I I've met people in cognitive decline
they call it Dimension some cases they
call it Alzheimer's diagnosed you know
people ask a question in three minutes
it's later they'll reask it and then
three minutes after that they'll re-ask
it again or tell a story again and again
and again I mean it's sad to see but you
know unfortunately in this case he's
supposed to be the leader of the Free
World that means he's not up to the job
to me
well Sean first I'm sorry I'm not
sitting there with you and Mark we had
back to school night for the kids and I
couldn't miss it but you know this is a
really serious topic and the ability to
remain focused and have fluid
conversations not getting distracted
that's really a Hallmark sign of an
intact executive function or you know
High cognition that's something we saw
of Senator Biden and even Vice President
Biden that's not necessarily something
that we're seeing with President Biden
with Gaff after Gaff and to be honest
it's concerning and so while not just we
are seeing it but the entire world is
watching a very changed man now it's one
thing when you see these signs of
potential cognitive decline in your
loved ones in your patients you know you
do a thorough assessment and then you
start taking what you know you say maybe
they can't make certain decisions make
sure they're in a safe place but the
bottom line is you get them evaluated
and you start decreasing some of their
responsibilities that's not what's
happening right now and unfortunately
this is unfolding for the entire world
to see and we're doing a disservice to
not only Joe Biden but our country for
not being able to have serious
conversations about what is going on
with President Biden and his cognition
and sadly in these cases it's always
degenerative it's never going to get
better it's only going to get worse
right Dr Siegel neurodegenerative
frontal over the brain uh Nicole made
the exactly the right point it's the
executive function to give the audience
an idea here can control your emotions
can't plan have trouble paying attention
can't multitask your socially
inappropriate you can't problem solve
that's him isn't it and by the way okay
he's the chief executive with impaired
executive function so if if you have a
relative Grandma uh Grandpa mom dad and
and they tell a story and then three
minutes later they retell the story or
they ask a question you give an answer
they keep asking the question over and
over again and that a pretty good sign
you don't really need to have examined
the patient that they've got a real
cognitive issues I always like to
examine the patient it's a real sign
you're right that there are cognitive
issues by the way if it's your
grandmother you put a gentle hand on on
their hand but if it's the president of
the United States you're worrying about
the nuclear button aren't you
boy that's a scary thought uh by the way
the faces showing to the world here the
president of Brazil is pissed off he
keeps saying to him are you hearing me
are you hearing me he's trying to talk
about bringing two countries together we
have to show strength to the world I
agree Dr Siegel by the way uh Dr Nicole
congrats on back to school night hope
you had a great time I give your kids
Straight A's for the year they're
already
sure they're doing great
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else